When a TV show is being created with children
in mind as the target audience, you would
think that the message would be kept as light
or clear-cut as possible.
But when the kids who love those shows grow
up, they start to see the straightforward
stories, characters, and messages in a brand
new light.
Or darker than ever before.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Dark Theories That
Completely Change Popular Kids Shows.
Spongebob Squarepants
This kids show has always teased some adult
jokes, starring a sponge living in Bikini
Bottom who's friends with Sandy Cheeks.
But the darker theory says that the show's
characters aren't just marine life who can
walk and talk, but creatures horribly mutated
by nuclear bomb testing.
Since America's nuclear testing was carried
out on Bikini Atoll in the Pacific Ocean,
the mutated fish might actually owe their
origins to the American military - if you
believe the theory.
Fresh Prince of Bel Air
One little fight is all it takes to send the
Fresh Prince to live with his rich aunt and
uncle in a Bel Air mansion, but according
to some fans, the Fresh Prince didn't make
it out of Philly at all.
That little fight was rougher than expected,
with his "rare" cab giving him a ride to Heaven,
not California.
All we know is that if the theory is true,
the Angels are a lot less accepting than we've
been told.
Inspector Gadget
This mechanical cop's origin isn't all that
different from Robocop's: the show never explains
what happened to Inspector Gadget, and he
can't remember the accident that saw his entire
body replaced by robotic tools.
One theory assumes that the show's bumbling
hero is obviously a flawed imitation of the
pre-accident inspector, rebuilt to keep his
legend alive.
But what of the real Gadget?
The broken, highly intelligent man who wakes
up to see he's been replaced by an idiot?
The leading theory is that he took a new name
as Dr. Claw, determined to kill his replacement
by any means necessary.
No wonder we never got to see his face.
The Tick
The cult comic book, cartoon and TV series
based on The Tick differ from one another,
but fans of the cartoon have come up with
one truly crazy theory.
The superhero is obviously a nod to Spider-Man
- but a bite from a tick won't give you superpowers...
it may only give you lyme disease.
The fans claim the entire story takes place
in the mind of a young boy who's fallen ill
with just that, imagining he'll soon become
a hero himself.
It explains why the show parodied the best-known
heroes, villains, and stories, and the stranger
characters based on the everyday things the
boy has to work with.
And with a character this crazy, it might
actually make sense.
The Jetsons Meet The Flintstones
Everyone's favourite stone age family was
just as well-known as their futuristic counterparts,
The Jetsons - but what if the two families
weren't separated by thousands of years at
all?
What if the Jetsons just happen to live among
the future's super-rich, in cities in the
sky driving flying cars, while Fred and Wilma
are forced to live like cavemen down below,
with only engineered dinosaurs to use for
technology.
It explains why dinosaurs can actually talk,
but in such a dark, dystopian theory, it's
no wonder fans have adopted it so quickly.
Winnie the Pooh
Sure, the characters of this book and animated
series are born in the mind of Christopher
Robin, but it didn't take long for their personalities
to grab the attention of mental health experts
and psychiatrists.
They soon argued that the cast offer perfect
examples of a wide range of psychiatric conditions:
Eeyore suffers from depression, Tigger is
hyperactive, Piglet succumbs to anxiety and
paranoid delusions, Rabbit shows signs of
OCD, Owl is dyslexic, and even Pooh compulsively
eats honey, no matter how much pain it may
cause him.
And here we thought it was all the rampant
illusions of a young boy's mind... okay, maybe
we should have caught this one sooner.
Pinky & The Brain
They started as a pair of supporting characters
on WB's Animaniacs, but these two laboratory
mice soon became stars, with one a genius,
and the other insane.
But what if fans have been getting their intellects
mixed up this whole time?
Brain might seem like the genius, but his
plans to "take over the world" are usually
nonsense, and never work.
Instead, it's Pinky who sees the problems
ahead of time, and is constantly keeping Brain
from taking over anything.
All this time, we never realized that Pinky
was just a weird genius defending the entire
world.
Seems fans owe him an apology.
Pokemon
Fans of the anime series know that its hero,
Ash Ketchum, never ages a day, or faces an
obstacle he can't beat.
But what if the ageless Ash can't be hurt,
because he's already dead?
It's a dark theory, but not a completely unhappy
one.
In the first episode, Ash and Pikachu are
almost killed by a flock of birds, before
a lightning attack wipes the birds - and Ash
- out.
When the two wake up, they catch a glimpse
of a legendary Pokemon flying overhead - one
that grants eternal happiness to anyone who
sees it - as fitting a metaphor for the afterlife
as we've ever heard.
Babar
A walking, talking elephant may seem innocent,
but it's hard to miss the real message at
work here.
After leaving the jungle behind for Paris,
an Old Lady teaches Babar how to dress, how
to read, and how to speak.
When he finally returns home with this education,
Babar is chosen as the new Elephant King,
re-shaping the Jungle and the animals in the
image of western society.
But remember: the story was written in turn-of-the-century
Europe, after the continent had spent centuries
trying to do the exact same thing to native
people around the world.
There were lessons to learn from Babar, but
we never realized that defending colonialism
or the "civilizing" of savage people was one
of them.
Saved By the Bell
Life couldn't be any better for Zack Morris:
he never has a bad day, can talk his way out
of any trouble, and is even able to stop time
itself to talk to the camera.
It's too good to be true... so what if it
is?
After all, the actual title and theme song
of "saved by the bell" makes school sound
like Zack's worst nightmare, just hoping for
the bell to set him free, before his alarm
clock starts it all over again.
Fans have an explanation: the show is a total
fantasy.
The real Zack isn't popular, good-looking,
or powerful - what audiences see is the life
he dreams about once his actual school day
has ended.
Talk about depressing... but also comforting.
Nobody could ever be that cool in real life.
Those are the dark and incredible fan theories
that forever changed our idea of hit childrens'
shows, but which ones did we miss?
Share them in the comments, and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!